Cornelius Vanderbilt - America’s First Tycoon
Cornelius Vanderbilt wasn’t exactly what
you would expect out of one of the richest
men in the world.
He was brutish, ill-mannered, barely literate,
and swore like a sailor.
But, perhaps, it was these same traits that
made him the definition of the American Dream
with all the good and the bad that that entailed.
He rose up from nothing; from less than nothing,
in fact.
His Dutch ancestors came to the New World
as indentured servants.
But through hard work and a keen eye towards
the future he amassed a fortune seldom seen
before that time.
That being said, he certainly was no saint.
Like all the other industrialists and speculators
of his time, Vanderbilt stepped on plenty
of toes to make his money.
He was ruthless in business and didn’t come
to be regarded as America’s first robber
baron for nothing.
Early Years
Cornelius Vanderbilt was born on May 27, 1794,
in Staten Island, New York City, to Cornelius
Van Der Bilt Sr. and Phebe Hand.
His ancestors had come to North America 150
years before he was born, back when the territory
was still part of a Dutch colony called New
Netherland.
His great great great grandfather was a man
named Jan Aertsen who immigrated to America
as an indentured servant.
By the time Cornelius was born, his family’s
station had improved, but not by much.
His parents were farmers and, to supplement
their income, his father also operated a ferry
that transported people and goods across the
New York Harbor.
Young Cornelius had a very strong work ethic
ever since he was a boy.
He labored on the farm from an early age and,
when he was 11 years old, he dropped out of
school to work full-time.
Although, clearly, things would work out well
for him, his lack of a formal education would
haunt Vanderbilt for the rest of his life.
Even in his later years, he struggled to write
English fluently and he was in the habit of
spelling words out phonetically.
It was part of the reason why he could never
find acceptance within the ranks of the wealthy
elite and was always regarded as a boorish
outsider.
Cornelius Vanderbilt might be remembered today
as a railroad tycoon, but it wasn’t trains
that made him his first fortune, but rather
ships.
His road to success started when he began
helping his father with his ferry service.
He learned the business and, by the time he
was 16, Vanderbilt was ready to branch out
on his own.
He borrowed $100 from his parents to buy his
own ship, a two-masted sailing vessel called
a periauger, and he paid them back by splitting
the profits with them.
Vanderbilt faced stiff competition, but his
strategy was to undercut everyone else by
offering cheap fares for transport between
Staten Island and Manhattan.
That being said, he was also an extremely
hard worker and constantly reinvested in his
business by acquiring more ships.
Vanderbilt quickly built up a reputation as
a reliable and assiduous ferryman.
In fact, even though he was still just a young
man, he earned the nickname “The Commodore,”
a moniker which he eagerly embraced and used
for the rest of his life.
Thanks to his good standing, Vanderbilt earned
an important government contract in 1812 when
war broke out between the United States and
the United Kingdom to supply the forts and
ferry soldiers around New York Harbor.
This period of conflict proved quite prosperous
for Cornelius Vanderbilt.
On the personal front, in 1813 he also married
his first wife, a cousin named Sophia Johnson.
They would go on to have 13 children together,
although they did not have a happy marriage.
By all accounts, Vanderbilt was not a very
caring father or husband.
It had often been rumored that he regularly
cheated on Sophia with prostitutes and even
had her committed to an insane asylum once.
Even though he was steadily amassing a small
fortune as he was building up his fleet, in
1817 Vanderbilt was offered a position he
couldn’t refuse - that of steamboat captain.
For years, the Commodore had developed an
interest in steam-powered ships as he considered
them superior to sailing vessels and the way
of the future.
Moreover, the offer came from Thomas Gibbons,
former Mayor of Savannah, Georgia, and one
of the wealthiest merchants around.
Vanderbilt assumed command of the steamboat
Mouse and started ferrying people between
New York and New Jersey while, simultaneously,
maintaining control of his growing business.
However, he soon discovered that the steamboat
trade in New York was run by a monopoly granted
by the New York State Legislature to two men:
Robert Livingston, an influential New York
politician and one of the Founding Fathers;
and Robert Fulton, the man credited with inventing
the first commercially-viable steamboat.
They were both dead by 1817, but their heirs
still had a vise-grip on the monopoly and
they had granted a license to run steamboats
on the Hudson River to former New Jersey senator
and governor Aaron Ogden.
This whole thing started from a personal rivalry
between Gibbons and Ogden.
At first, the former tried to bankrupt the
latter by undercutting his prices.
Eventually, Ogden sued and the matter went
to court where it actually resulted in a very
important, landmark ruling.
In the case of Gibbons v. Ogden (1824), the
Supreme Court concluded that the commerce
clause in the Constitution which granted the
federal government the power to decide how
interstate commerce was conducted also extended
to waterway navigation.
Therefore, the state of New York had no right
to grant a monopoly in the first place, and
the court ruled in favor of Gibbons.
To support his employer, Vanderbilt had his
own case against Ogden, even hiring Daniel
Webster, a noted statesman, to argue his case
before the Supreme Court.
However, it was never heard as it was unnecessary
after the ruling in the previous case.
Even so, Vanderbilt deserves no credit as
some sort of pioneering trustbuster.
He only fought the monopoly because it worked
against him.
In the future, he would have no problem using
them to his advantage.
The Birth of an Empire
In 1826, Thomas Gibbons died, leaving his
business in the hands of his son, William.
Cornelius Vanderbilt considered the wealthy
merchant as somewhat of a mentor to him, but
he didn’t like William as he considered
him weak.
He stayed on for a few more years until he
got his finances in order, but Vanderbilt
left the business in 1828 and broke off on
his own again.
He even bought his own steamboat - a 145-ton,
106-ft sidewheeler called the Citizen.
This vessel was quickly followed by others
in the next few years.
As we previously mentioned, Vanderbilt regularly
took the profits he made and reinvested back
into his business, steadily building a fleet
of steamboats and opening new routes for his
ferries such as the Long Island Sound, Albany,
Connecticut, and Providence.
Of course, he faced competition in all the
new areas he expanded to, but these companies
usually found out quickly that it was dangerous
to go against the Commodore.
He was ruthless when it came to business.
Because he had a wealth of resources, his
go-to strategy involved undercutting his opponents’
prices, oftentimes to the point where they
would either go bankrupt or be forced to sell
to him.
In the cases of some companies that also had
deep pockets, they would often pay Vanderbilt
large sums of money to leave the area and
take his ferries on another route.
One notable example was when the Commodore
wanted to put his ships on the Hudson River,
traveling between New York City and Albany.
This route was dominated by a monopoly called
the Hudson River Steamboat Association, but
Vanderbilt only saw it as a challenge.
This was at a time when Andrew Jackson was
running a populist presidential campaign based
around “the common man.”
He had gained popularity by portraying himself
as a man of the people, fighting the corrupt
aristocracy.
Vanderbilt did the same thing.
It wasn’t hard, after all, he did come from
a working class family and his behavior and
demeanor were certainly more at home in a
bar than a banquet.
He dubbed his ferry service the “People’s
Line” and offered cheap rates that working
men could afford.
Unsurprisingly, this strategy worked really
well and, soon enough, the Steamboat Association
offered him $100,000 to leave the Hudson River,
plus another $5,000 a year to stay away.
Going into Nicaragua
For years, Vanderbilt focused his business
mainly in the region between Boston and New
York, but he organized a major expansion in
1849 prompted by the California Gold Rush.
He knew that hundreds of thousands, even millions
of people would be traveling that way, many
of them looking to settle permanently in the
unorganized California territory which, at
that point, was still lobbying for statehood.
When California finally became a state in
1850, demand for transportation between the
East and West Coasts skyrocketed and, all
of a sudden, a new multi-million dollar venture
was born.
Unsurprisingly, Vanderbilt wanted a piece
of that pie and started sending steamships
along this route.
Back then, the only way to travel from New
York to San Francisco by water was to round
Cape Horn at the southerly tip of South America.
However, this trip was long and time meant
money.
It was still quicker and less dangerous than
traveling overland across the United States,
but Vanderbilt sought a way to speed up the
journey even more.
The solution was a canal across Nicaragua.
It would have shaved days off each trip.
Vanderbilt even founded the Accessory Transit
Company or ATC whose purpose was to secure
transportation across the Central American
country.
However, for various political and economical
reasons, the project never went into construction
and, eventually, it was established that a
canal across Panama would be more efficient.
That being said, the ATC was not a failed
venture.
Quite the opposite, in fact.
Vanderbilt may not have been able to secure
a route that took passengers from the East
Coast to the West Coast on a single ship,
but he developed a course that was a mix of
land and water travel.
His customers would board a steamboat in New
York which took them to the eastern coast
of Nicaragua.
From there, the goods and passengers were
loaded onto smaller vessels capable of going
up the San Juan River and crossing Lake Nicaragua.
When they reached land, they traveled by stagecoach
to the western coast where they boarded a
different steamer headed for San Francisco.
It was the fastest and cheapest way of reaching
the East Coast and it made Vanderbilt a nice
bundle of money, but he didn’t get everything
he aimed for.
What the Commodore wanted was a big, fat government
contract to also transport mail, but it went
instead to some of his competitors who founded
the Pacific Mail Steamship Company and the
United States Mail Steamship Company.
Even so, the Commodore still had an ace up
his sleeve as his opponents used a route across
Panama.
It was similar, but longer, so Vanderbilt
went back to his tried-and-true method of
slashing his prices to steal all of his competition’s
clientele.
It worked, but when Gold Rush fever started
to die down, the Commodore saw no reason to
keep this route so he accepted a large monthly
stipend from his opponents to close down the
ATC.
The War of the Commodores
While Vanderbilt was expanding his operations
to the West Coast, he also started offering
transatlantic journeys to Europe.
Again, this venture proved profitable, but
the Commodore also learned that not even he
was infallible.
As before, his new route had competition - the
British Cunard Steamship Line, among others.
Vanderbilt tried to squash it like he always
did, but failed.
The British government was keen to see the
company succeed against American and German
firms so they provided a low-interest loan
plus a generous annual subsidy to ensure that
the Cunard Line had the capital to both build
top-of-the-line ships and to compete with
Vanderbilt’s undercutting tactics.
Another unexpected setback occurred in 1853
when Vanderbilt saw fit, for the first time
ever, to take a vacation.
He was almost 60 years old and had been working
for most of his life so the Commodore decided
that, if he were to go on holiday, he would
do it in style.
Vanderbilt bought a giant, luxurious yacht
he dubbed the North Star and took his whole
family on a grand tour of Europe, at a total
cost of half a million dollars.
Whilst he was vacationing, the Commodore left
the management of ATC in Nicaragua in the
hands of two men, Charles Morgan and Cornelius
Garrison.
In came another American named William Walker
who was a filibuster which, back then, meant
that he was a sort of insurgent who would
rally troops to invade parts of Latin America,
take over by force and set up English-speaking
colonies.
There were a few filibusters during the 19th
century as Manifest Destiny was still a big
thing, but Walker was probably the most famous
of them all because he actually succeeded
twice...sort of.
First, in 1853, Walker and dozens of his followers
invaded Mexico and actually conquered the
Baja California Territory by assaulting its
capital of La Paz and capturing the governor.
He then declared it the Republic of Lower
California, a sovereign state with him as
president.
Of course, it didn’t last long.
As Walker and his men ran out of supplies,
desertions became frequent and he also had
to relocate his headquarters several times
because the Mexican army was just a little
upset with him.
In the end, he had no choice but to cross
the border and surrender to an American army.
He was arrested and charged with an illegal
war, but was actually acquitted after giving
an impassioned speech that swayed the jury.
All Walker learned from this experience was
that he needed better financing.
In 1855, he was ready to try again, this time
in Nicaragua.
While the Commodore was still on his extended
vacation, Walker approached Morgan and Garrison
and, in exchange for their support of his
coup, he promised that, once he was the new
president, he would revoke ATC’s charter
and issue a new own in their name.
And that’s exactly what happened.
In 1856, William Walker became the new President
of the Republic of Nicaragua and a new transit
business owned by Morgan and Garrison had
exclusive rights to operate in the country.
Understandably, Vanderbilt was furious when
he learned of their treachery.
According to an apocryphal story, he wrote
them a short and ominous letter where he said
"Gentlemen: You have undertaken to cheat me.
I won't sue you, for the law is too slow.
I'll ruin you.
Yours truly, Cornelius Vanderbilt."
And that is, pretty much, what he did.
He set up another transit company that passed
through Panama with dirt cheap prices to steal
their customers.
He refused to take any passengers to or from
Nicaragua and convinced the nearby Central
American countries to not recognize Walker’s
government.
Back in the United States, he sued Morgan
and Garrison in a legal battle the American
media dubbed “The War of the Commodores.”
And, most decisively, he sent agents into
Nicaragua to cause chaos and convince the
locals to rebel against Walker.
It worked and, in 1857, the filibuster surrendered
to the U.S. army again.
Meanwhile, Morgan and Garrison’s business
went bankrupt and Vanderbilt assumed control
over the region’s transit system again.
As far as Walker was concerned, he once again
was acquitted as many Americans regarded him
as a hero.
Then he went and tried the same thing in Honduras,
but things went a little different that time.
The Honduran authorities captured him and,
in 1860, executed him by firing squad.
From Ships to Trains
The 1860s were a troubling time for Cornelius
Vanderbilt, as they were for most Americans,
because of the Civil War.
On a personal level, he suffered losses.
His youngest and favorite son, George Washington
Vanderbilt, died in the war after contracting
malaria.
An inveterate misogynist, the Commodore never
showed much affection to his daughters and
he considered his other two sons to be disappointments.
One of them, Cornelius Jeremiah, was a degenerate
gambler who was on bad terms with his father
after the elder Cornelius locked him up in
a lunatic asylum.
The other one, William Henry, the Commodore
simply regarded as weak and good for nothing.
Eventually, Vanderbilt changed his tune about
William after he took a poor farm in Staten
Island and made it profitable.
Since then, Vanderbilt integrated his son
more and more into his business and, eventually,
it was William who inherited most of his father’s
estate.
In 1868, Vanderbilt’s wife, Sophia, died.
After her passing, the Commodore began visiting
mediums, particularly the Claflin sisters.
He fell in love with the younger sibling,
Tennessee Claflin, and, according to some
sources, even proposed marriage.
This worried his family who were concerned
that Vanderbilt might leave his fortune to
a stranger so they played Cupid and fixed
him up with a distant cousin who was four
decades younger than him.
This cousin had an unusual name for a woman.
She was called Frank Armstrong.
We’re not exactly sure why, but at least
one historian asserts that this was due to
a misguided promise from her parents to a
close friend to name their first child Frank,
even if it wasn’t a boy.
Anyway, Cornelius and Frank eloped in Canada
in 1869.
As far as the Claflin sisters were concerned,
they soon gave up their spiritualist ways
and became noted suffragists.
With Vanderbilt’s backing, they also got
into the business world and became the first
women to open a brokerage firm on Wall Street.
The older sister dropped the “Claflin”
from her name and became known as Victoria
Woodhull, the first ever female candidate
for the Presidency of the United States.
Going back to the Civil War, this period represented
a huge shift in Vanderbilt’s business practices.
No longer impressed with the capabilities
of steamboats, he now looked to the railroad
as the future.
Truth be told, the Commodore had shown interest
in trains for decades.
He might have invested in them even sooner
if not for his involvement in one of the first
fatal train accidents in American history.
All the way back in 1833, the Hightstown Rail
Accident occurred in New Jersey when a carriage
caught fire, caused an axle to break and derailed
the train.
One person was killed and dozens were injured.
Among them was Cornelius Vanderbilt who broke
his leg in the crash.
In the decades following that event, the Commodore
only had minor dealings with the rail industry.
He occasionally bought shares in new railroads,
but most of his efforts were concentrated
in Nicaragua.
Eventually, though, he could no longer ignore
the potential for huge profits offered by
this new mode of transportation.
Starting with the late 1850s, he began selling
off his fleet of ships.
During the Civil War, he even donated his
most prized vessel, the appropriately-named
Vanderbilt, to the Union Navy to use against
the Confederates who dominated the seas with
the help of their ironclads.
Vanderbilt even acted as advisor when it came
to all things maritime, but he refused an
official position in Lincoln’s cabinet as
he wanted to avoid politics at any cost.
The Commodore wasn’t very interested in
building railroads.
He preferred to buy ones that already existed
and form a monopoly.
His first major purchase was the New York
and Harlem Railroad.
At the time, it wasn’t considered particularly
valuable as it only ran trains for part of
the journey before connecting to horse-drawn
carriages.
However, it had prime position as the only
railway that entered downtown Manhattan.
Vanderbilt brought in his son, William, as
vice-president of the Harlem line and, together,
they soon made it profitable.
Next up, he took control of the Hudson River
Railroad in 1864 and the New York Central
Railroad in 1867.
He also bought smaller, adjacent lines to
consolidate them all into one giant railroad
empire.
Vanderbilt was already 70 years old when he
decided to get into railroads.
He took a backseat role and mostly delegated
orders to William and other subordinates,
although he did enjoy taking inspection trips
to oversee his domains.
It seemed that his ruthlessness had subsided
somewhat with age.
Very rarely were there any cutthroat tactics
to get his way.
More often than not, Vanderbilt preferred
simply to buy enough stock in a railroad until
he became the majority shareholder and then
appointed himself president.
He even dabbled in philanthropy, donating
$1 million to establish the Vanderbilt University
in Nashville, Tennessee.
The last major addition to the Vanderbilt
empire occurred in 1876 when the tycoon acquired
the Canada Southern Railway.
Soon after that, the 82-year-old Commodore
fell gravely ill.
His death was slow and painful, being bedridden
for months before passing away on January
4, 1877.
He remained a cantankerous, grumpy malcontent
until the very end.
On his better days, he would curse out his
physicians and throw water bottles at them.
On one occasion, he had to be physically restrained
after trying to attack the media men who were
keeping watch outside of his house to report
on his death.
Vanderbilt’s death was followed by a long
and messy lawsuit over his assets.
Not wanting to split up his fortune, he left
around $90 million of his $105 million estate
to his son, William, while Frank and the rest
of his children received much smaller amounts
in cash or stock.
And, in case you were wondering, that fortune
means well over $200 billion in modern currency.